one of the things that people are very
much confused by in the modern world is
what archaic people meant by gods and
that's because whatever the deities were
that had the mode of force that archaic
people attributed to the God seemed to
have disappeared in modern culture now
the Union hypothesis is that's because
they turned into psychological traits
fundamentally or motivational forces so
what the what archaic societies would
describe as gods we would describe as
motivational forces so for example Venus
is a goddess the goddess of love and we
would associate her power with love and
sex fundamentally and the reason that
that's a reasonable association from the
archaic standpoint is because the motive
quality that makes up what Venus
represents is transpersonal which means
it's not limited to one person and it's
immortal in that the motive force that
characterizes sexual affiliation exists
whether or not a single individual
exists so it's transpersonal has the
force of a personality because if you
fall in love you're motivated by a
certain set of standards and
perspectives right if you're gripped by
beauty say or if you're gripped by lust
that imposes a particular view of the
world on you and impels your action
sometimes despite your will and so that
would be equivalent from the archaic
perspective to possession and it's
clearly the case that archaic societies
who were engaged in warfare for example
would conduct rituals to ensure that the
Warriors that made up their societies
were in fact possessed by the correct
God so might be Mars for example the
Roman god of war so that on the
battlefield they exhibited the proper
characteristics of somebody who was in a
battle right rage
you can think rage so possession by the
God of War would be equivalent to this
possession by a state of rage now it's
not quite that simple it isn't only that
archaic people externalize motive forces
and gave them the status of daddies what
they did was more complex than that and
I think you can understand that a little
bit better if you start to if you start
to give some thought to the
modern behavioral notion of the stimulus
as stimulus is a very very weird concept
because the behaviorists who weren't
interested in taking apart what was
inside the brain would attribute motive
force to the stimulus right they'd say
if you present an animal with the
stimulus he will therefore act and that
meant that the behaviors were making the
presupposition that the motive power
resided in some manner in the stimulus
well and why would they think like that
well it's an archaic mode of thought in
a sense you can imagine a child saying
one of my friends today made me really
angry right which means that the child
is essentially conflating his or her own
internal emotional state with the
proximal stimulus that gave rise to that
state and you see complex associations
like that taking place with regards to
the apprehension of beauty say because
beauties are very very complex and
difficult to localize phenomena if
you're very attracted to someone are you
attracted by them well in a sense of
course you are because there they are
but in another sense you're not at all
because what's happening is that you're
engaged as much in the interaction as
anything that's motivating you from the
outside world and I think that partly
accounts for your sense of foolishness
especially if the person that you're
attracted to doesn't return your
attraction I mean you know that from
your perceptual perspective you're
attracted and dominated by the object
but by the same token you know entirely
that easy as it is to presume it's them
and their faults a pretty much it all
has to do with you so in the modern
world where we've been able to separate
out the object and the motive force of
the object the deities have sort of
moved inside of us and become
psychological forces but you can
understand if you think about it in this
manner that things weren't so clear
prior to the dawn of the empirical age
that gives you a little bit of
background with regards to what the
notion of deity meant to archaic
societies who still utilize those
notions as explanatory terms okay so we
know that if you're caught up in one of
these little world games that you may be
motivated by something very very
fundamental right tendency that
transcends you the tendency to propagate
yourself say Freud's fundamental
motivational level sexual affiliation or
the tendency to maintain yourself those
you could say are the fundamental gods
of existence the fundamental driving
forces and it's there it's the
interaction of those two forces over
great periods of time that produce the
great diversity of life and and human
life that we see before us and each of
those fundamental most fundamental of
gods have their differentiated many and
so to speak so that well engaged in the
meta goal of self-preservation
you act out plots of hunger and plots of
thirst and you move from cold to hot or
from hot to cold depending on your
particular on your particular on the
particular temperature of your
surroundings or with regards to self
propagation you're attracted to people
who are repelled by them for reasons
that are frequently absolutely beyond
your comprehension by the way so I just
found out this week and this is
absolutely staggering I think that if
you if you run an experiment on a group
of women and you track their menstrual
cycle and then you give them t-shirts
that men have worn to smell that women
who are ovulating like the smell of
symmetrical men better than asymmetrical
men so and that's partly because
symmetrical men are probably more
healthy but this is a good example of
how the motive forces that configure
your world are dependent on instinctual
forces that are not only beyond your
consciousness but they're beyond even at
the moment any of our explicit
explanations
[Music]
so another finding that's very similar
that I came across recently turns out
that mice will not mate with mice that
have Rh blood factors that are likely to
produce unfit offspring the more closely
genetically related the Rh factors the
more likely there is to be a catastrophe
with regards to offspring and the mice
seem to detect the Rh factor by smell so
recently this was run by with women and
it is also the case that women prefer
men whose Rh factors are at an optimal
distance from them in terms of smell so
this is some example of how these
unbelievably archaic systems because
like the olfactory systems are
unbelievably archaic produce alterations
in worldview at a level that's massively
below consciousness so underneath your
cortical shell which is tonically
inhibiting all your emotional and
motivational systems lies all these
motivational and emotional systems and
they have branches that grow up into the
cortex and may have the capacity to
control your behavior completely and
voluntarily so for example if you're
gripped by fear if you're gripped by
fear it's very very difficult to
overcome that voluntarily and at least
initially you won't be able to which is
to say that when the chips are down the
underlying motivational and emotional
systems have control okay so then what
happens from that perspective then what
happens when you encounter something you
don't understand and I think the best
way to explain it is something like
generalized disinhibition which is that
all your underlying motivational and
emotional systems are more or less
disinhibited simultaneously and the
reason for that is because you want to
be maximally prepared to do whatever the
hell is necessary to do when you're
somewhere that you don't understand and
because you don't know what that thing
is going to be all your systems go on
and when psychologists talk about stress
which is an abysmal word right it means
everything and nothing when
psychologists talk about stress what
they mean is generalized disinhibition
of emotion and motivation
[Music]
then you come to the case of ancient
Egypt one of the things le atta points
out which i think is really interesting
I mean really phenomenal the story I'm
going to tell you right now was
essentially revealed in Egyptian culture
at the dawn of the culture rather than
developing over the course of the
culture so the Egyptians had a
revelation right immediately that the
most fundamental of gods was the one who
created as a consequence of his tongue
in his speech very much akin to the
sumerian idea with regards to Marduk and
also to later judeo-christian ideas so
here's this story there's four players
in this drama okay
there's Osiris his wife Isis Horus their
son and Seth and Seth is Osiris as evil
brother
okay now Osiris was a remarkable guy he
was the founder of the Egyptian state
from the mythological perspective so
kind of like Romulus and Remus for Rome
a myth or like George Washington for the
u.s. right a mythologized figure who
represented all of the pharaohs and
people for that matter who'd actually
constructed the egyptian state Osiris
farther of Egypt so to speak but Osiris
is kind of old and little archaic and
maybe a little bit senile and even
possibly a little bit naive in that you
know even no matter how great you were
in your youth as time goes on you lose
contact with environmental
transformations and the old rules that
you live by are not necessarily
applicable to the present and some of
those things that you ignore become
paramount of important importance and it
turns out that Osiris has an evil
brother Seth and Seth eventually turns
into Satan as mythology develops through
the centuries and Seth is a nasty guy
right I mean what he wants more than
anything is undeserved dominion over the
Egyptian state now saris because he's
not paying attention and because he
isn't sufficiently cognizant anymore of
the power of evil more or less ignores
his evil brother who in turn chops him
into pieces
and then distributes his pieces all over
the Egyptian state now you might say why
didn't he just kill up right I mean you
think chopping him up would kill him but
he's a God you can't just kill him the
reason in mythology and you see this in
movies as well where the villain never
quite dies or the hero never quite dies
is because even if you eliminate
individual embodiments of what those
figures represent new embodiments
manifest themselves virtually
immediately so one of the things
mythology is quite clear about is that
you never win a final battle with evil
it's a it's a permanent property of the
world so anyways seth hacks up Osiris
spreads him all over the land
Osiris ends up living a kind of shadowy
and nebulous ghost-like existence down
in the underworld and seth becomes the
ruler of the state a nasty story alright
bucko Cirrus has Isis as a wife now Isis
had a huge cult she was a powerful
goddess goddess of the underworld a kind
of combination of Kali and Diana so to
speak capable of tremendous destructive
power but also the source of all good
things something very much like time at
now Isis got wind of her husband's
disintegration so to speak and she went
searching around Egypt till she found
his fellows and with that she makes
herself pregnant okay so what does that
mean exactly
it means something like this the
collapse of any great order brings with
it new potential and I think this is
something that capitalism has way over
forms of government like communism
capitalism has mechanisms in place to
allow large structures that are no
longer meeting their function to
collapse but frequently when they
collapse it's not like they disintegrate
into dust right they disintegrate into
sub components so to speak many of which
then come to terms with the fact that
the order has collapsed and build
something new so you can't get rid of
culture so easily
hack it up into bits you can disembody
it so to speak you can spread it all
over the state you can introduce chaos
into it but that's that's something that
has the potential of new birth like the
phoenix rising from the ashes so anyways
isis who's the matrix whose time out
gets Osiris's phallus which is the
container of the germ of of culture
right that the the phenomena that's
capable of the seminal idea and she
makes herself pregnant and she gives
birth to horus who's the long-lost son
of the rightful king right a very
typical mythological motif
okay so Horus is alienated from the
kingdom which is another very common
mythological motif you know like how
King Arthur for example is raised by
commoners this same story pops up in in
in the story of Christ for example
because Christ has heavenly parents but
then he also has his kind of ordinary
parents and it's a very common motif
anyway so Horus grows out outside of the
classical structure of the Egyptian
state which is tilted terribly towards
evil because Seth is dominated because
Osiris was too blind to his evil brother
to take appropriate defensive actions
and he grows to maturity and then he
decides like all rightful sons of the
long-lost King to reclaim his heritage
so he goes back to Egypt right and he
has this vicious battle with Seth and in
the process seth tears out one of his
eyes I'll find what and that's an
indication of just exactly how
devastating a battle with the forces of
evil so to speak precisely are they
represent a critical threat to the
integrity of consciousness right that's
why he loses an eye well luckily enough
Horus has got his act together and he
does defeat Seth and he banishes him and
he gets the eye back and then you think
okay great
pop the eye back in become Emperor
everything's fine now let's backtrack a
little bit and think about this
politically now the Egyptians had this
really weird idea they had the idea that
the living Pharaoh was the living
Pharaoh and the dead Pharaoh at the same
time that makes no sense rationale but
it makes a lot of
sense from a narrative perspective
because what they were saying is
something like this look you got to
think that when you become king or when
you become president or when you take on
a role of that absolute magnitude that
then you're partly you but you're also
partly this role and there's really no
way out of that right and the role is
composed of the unbelievable weight of
the cultural tradition that you're
representing and you can say well that's
true for being King for being present
but it's also true if you become a
doctor or a lawyer any sort of
specialized occupation it's partly you
because you're embodying the role but
it's partly the role too so the Pharos
the live Pharaoh and the dead Pharaoh
because the dead Pharaoh represents
culture right king is dead long live the
king okay but paralleling that idea was
the idea that the Pharaoh was not only
the dead Pharaoh but and the live
Pharaoh at the same time but that he was
Osiris and Horus at the same time but
then you think in this story
Horus has taken over Seth he's got his
eye back he can be king but he isn't
King yet and this is where the Egyptians
really get their act together and and I
think of the two stories that I'm
telling you this is the one that has the
most significance I think for modern
people because we're so likely to
sidestep our obligation to our culture
whatever that happens to be so instead
of popping this eye back in his head
which is the first thing you think he
does he decides he's going to go back to
the underworld where Osiris is living in
this ghost-like and dead manner since
he's being chopped up by Seth so he goes
down into the underworld which is no
piece of cake and he finds Osiris there
in this kind of half-dead state and he
gives him his eye and that enlightens
Osiris right it gives envision and so
then he takes Osiris back to Egypt arm
and arm so to speak and it's the
conjunction of Osiris and Horus that
constitutes the basis for Egyptian
sovereignty and that is bloody brilliant
right because the Egyptians figured out
that so Horace's top is Marduk for all
intents and purposes right he's this
avenging hero in the Egyptian story
he fights political corruption rather
than chaos but you can understand that
those are two flip sides of the hero
archetype they they are they here
archetype has two basic elements one is
the confrontation of the terrible aspect
of nature chaos in its most brutal form
and the other is the confrontation with
the archaic aspect of culture and in
some ways those aren't distinguishable
because if culture isn't archaic chaos
never makes itself present so which is
to say you can't separate our political
degradation from environmental
degradation say it's the same idea
[Music]
so anyways
horace has this great idea he needs his
father right and i told you about the
same motif emerging in pinocchio we
already looked at that right Pinocchio
doesn't become genuine until he risks
his life saving his father alright so
the same thing is happening in this
particular situation so that's pretty
cool so then you get this situation
where the Egyptians characterized
sovereignty as the capability to
overcome evil in the political domain
combined with and that's a youthful
capability right combined with the
wisdom of the past alright then you look
at that from a political perspective and
you find out already that the Egyptians
viewed the Pharaoh as the live Pharaoh
and the dead Pharaoh simultaneously but
then you find out something else that's
interesting and it gives you some really
real insight into just exactly how
bloody powerful these ideas were so you
think what did the Egyptians do with
their spare time and then you think well
they built the pyramids right I mean and
that was no trivial undertaking it was
sort of the 5000 BC equivalent of flying
to Mars and I mean the pyramids are
pretty impressive now but they were a
hell of a lot more impressive in their
original form because they were in the
middle of an immense complex and the
pyramids were dedicated to the
immortality of the Pharaoh and the
Pharaoh was possessed by a spirit called
kha and Kyle was his his immortal spirit
and it was the union of Horace and
Osiris okay so Egyptian society was
dedicated to daya fiying
the immortal spirit of the Pharaoh the
union of Horace and Osiris and it was
this Union that gave the it was this
identification with this union that gave
the
Eero a phenomena the Egyptians called
MOT and not was like truth or good order
and you can think about it as conscience
in a census if the Pharaoh was was
utilizing the union of Horace oh no no
serious that he would have an intuitive
ability to decide what the appropriate
course of order was and so the Egyptians
would say for example when the Pharaoh
came into the court and say the Sun has
risen and by that they meant that the
power that reigned over the Dominion of
the night had arrived they
conceptualized mad as the capacity to
put order in the place of chaos
essentially formally so they assimilated
the union of Horace and Osiris with the
capability of putting order in the face
of chaos they regarded that as immortal
and they spent all of the excess
resources of their society glorifying
that idea and you think you don't
produce something like the pyramids
without really being possessed by an
idea right this is no trivial
undertaking it's it's going over a
period of several hundred if not several
thousand years it takes an awful lot of
work so this idea of the immortality of
the union of Horace and Osiris and its
association with sovereignty was an
absolutely potent idea for the Egyptians
it gave their whole culture motive force
okay so the Egyptians thought Pharaoh's
immortal and that's the reason why and
we more or less partake in his
immortality by being his subject so that
was a pretty good deal but then the
Iliad appoints out something very
interesting and this is called the
democratization of Osiris and what you
found was that initially there were
certain symbolic representations
representing the immortality of the
Pharaoh that could only be used by the
Pharaoh but as Egyptian culture
continued to develop then the symbolic
representations of immortality started
to be adopted by the aristocracy now
what did that mean it meant that this
this process that the Egyptians had
conceptualized as integral to the order
of the state was no longer solely
embodied in the hands of the Pharaoh
right it had started to drift down the
power hierarchy into the aristocracy
okay well then you think what happens
after that so
the end of Egyptian society the
aristocrats were characterized by an
identity with the union of Horace and
Osiris right sovereignty had started to
spread itself and you think what starts
to happen with the Greeks right the
Greeks attribute sovereignty to every
male Greek barbarians no women no but at
least all males right you get a
beginning of a democratic notion there
the Jews developing ideas that if not
derived from Egypt we're at least
similar in structure to Egyptian ideas
say not the aristocracy not the Pharaoh
but every individual has the capacity of
establishing a direct relationship with
the form of the deity right then you
have a Christian revolution that follows
that where the idea that sovereignty
inheres in the individual is distributed
to everyone right everyone male female
criminal non criminal murderer rapist
taxman you name it sovereignty inheres
within them and it's on that soil that
our whole democratic culture emerges
these unbelievably archaic ideas first
acted out right first embodied in ritual
first dramatized then only told his
stories developing more and more
coherence over over stretches of time of
thousands of years not hundreds of years
but thousands of years becoming more
coherent becoming more pointed becoming
more relevant with regards to their
embodiment then starting to become
understood explicitly and distributed
through the entire society
[Music]
and it's on that ground that our world
rests not on the ground of rationality
as established and say Europe in 1500
what we have is much more profound and
solid and deep than any mere rational
construction it's it's a form of
government in equilibrate estate so to
speak
that's a consequence of an emergent if
not evolutionary at least social
evolutionary process and I would say
that it stems much farther back than
that because you could imagine something
like this
look if this ideal personality that
should be sovereign is represented by
the optimal combination of creativity
and traditionalism say if that's the
optimal combination and if we're
prepared to regard that as optimal if
that's what you perceive when you
perceive someone that you respect and
admire then you could say that success
in our social hierarchies is predicated
on the degree to which you actually
embody that combination and then you see
an interaction between individuals
success and this social construction
that would be an interaction that
extends over the centuries or even
thousands of centuries so that as these
ideas become more and more developed we
become more and more adapted to
embodying them as a consequence of
evolutionary pressure so it's not just
cultural it's also biological so our
political presuppositions rest on a
cultural basis which is unbelievably
archaic resting in turn on something
even lower than that and I think
examples of that are are those that I've
provided you with already we know for
example that chimps who have to live in
a dormant are very aggressive especially
the male's but they're also very
cooperative so the males who are
aggressive spend a substantial amount of
time repairing social boundaries in the
aftermath of a aggressive incident
because they're just as concerned with
keeping the bloody hierarchy intact as
they are and climbing it they have to be
and we know that even wolves won't kill
a
Wolffe once they've defeated it they
allow the subordinate wolf to maintain
its own existence right they have this
notion this procedural notion that even
those entities that appear insignificant
may in some manner that's beyond speech
still contribute to the integrity of the
whole and that's an idea that's very
much similar to our notion that
sovereignty inheres in the individual
right we've taken it further no matter
what you do even if you're in clear
violation of the law your rights remain
intact because no matter how old caste
you are and how a parent lis beyond
redemption your existence may still
contribute something to the integrity of
the whole and as far as I'm concerned
that doesn't appear to be a metaphorical
idea if you dismiss it
you cannot dismiss it without
simultaneously dismissing the ground on
which our states rest and so then you
have to ask yourself are you willing to
do that and if the answer is no well
then you have to start doing you have to
start to question what it is that you
actually believe because if you buy the
doctrine of natural rights which you do
you act it out then all of this follows
in its wake
or it rests on sound and it bloody well
better not rest on sound
you